cada año este agricultor de manzanas
produce un millón de libras si un millón
de libras pero también cada año él
enfrenta a un problema del cambio del
precio alrededor de ciertas cifras
digamos que algunas ocasiones después de
la cosecha éstas se venden a 30 centavos
por libra y esto le ayuda a su economía
pero hay otras ocasiones cuando el
precio baja a los 10 centavos y esto no
le alcanza ni siquiera para cubrir sus
gastos y por otro lado tenemos una
cadena de pasteles que está justo aquí y
ellos se especializan haciendo país de
manzana entonces cuando el precio de las
manzanas se eleve ellos no alcanzan a
cubrir el precio de sus costos basados
en los precios que ellos dan lo que esto
ocasionaría pérdidas pero si los precios
de las manzanas van a las bajas a ellos
les beneficia y bueno ellos aún así les
preocupa la volatilidad que pueda llegar
a tener el precio pues imagínate
arriesgar todo el tiempo las ganancias y
puedes llegar a pasar hambre entonces lo
que ellos hacen es estar atentos a
cuando la cosecha está por llegar y los
agricultores especulen sus precios a la
baja y tengan miedo así que a ellos les
convenga de comprar estos precios bajos
respecto al precio de los países si
estos se van a la baja y se tienen que
vender a 10 centavos por libra ellos se
irán a la quiebra pero bueno aunque los
precios después se elevarán a los 30
centavos por libras aún así estarán
latentes aisha una quiebra y que se
podría hacer pues llegar a un acuerdo
tomar un tiempo específico sin tomar en
cuenta el precio del mercado y la fecha
actual de la cosecha y hacer un contrato
en donde la cadena se comprometa a
comprar un millón de libras en una fecha
determinada por ejemplo después de la
cosecha y el precio sería de 20 centavos
por libra y bueno el beneficio de esto
para la cadena sería que con este precio
ellos estarían asegurando que aunque el
precio del mercado esté por arriba de
los 20 centavos ellos sólo pagarían
estos mismos garantizándoles una mínima
ganancia que no les provoque pérdidas
así de esta manera ellos pueden prever y
planear con su dinero sin limitarse por
algún riesgo y de igual forma funciona
para el agricultor él con este precio de
20 centavos por libra está garantizando
cubrir al menos sus gastos como el pago
de los empleados el pago propio o poder
alguna familia y todo esto puede
planificarlo el agricultor sin
arriesgarse a la volatilidad que hay en
el mercado pero todo esto que acabamos
de hacer establece es lo que normalmente
se conoce como howard o un contrato a
término que como puedes ver es un
acuerdo entre dos partes que se tienen
la obligación de llevar a cabo en el
futuro el precio pactado de algún
producto y en el momento de la cosecha
en este caso ellos podrán ver si las
ganancias están siendo mayores con el
contrato y digamos que la fecha fuera no
sé el 15 de noviembre por así decirlo
cuando este agricultor esté obligado a
entregar un millón de libras y la cadena
de los países esté obligada a producir
el dinero para comprar a 20 centavos por
libra la manzana o viene a producir los
200 mil dólares para pagar si te das
cuenta lo bueno de todo esto es que
ambos salen beneficiados y así evitar
volatilidades y todo ese rollo del
mercado asegurando tener suficiente
dinero para sobrevivir finalmente todo
esto es por un acuerdo